in an alternate universe we have done
this before haven't we guys we have i'm
zendaya i am tom jacob
and this is the wide auto complete in an
interview
[Music]
and when i say alternate universe i mean
just like a few years ago
[Music]
quite stressful on this yeah i mean i
feel like you guys got way more famous
so that's probably going to be a part of
it okay so i guess we'll start now
what are tom holland spider-man's powers
tom holland's spider-man so like not
toby not andrews tom holland t-h's
uh super strength
i have you guys i guess you guys are a
superpower
that's a cool superpower
friends the other two were such losers
what is tom holland's middle name easy
oh
you want me to say it well i want to
test you guys out let's stanley up all
right
what does tom holland eat for breakfast
a whole load of different things the
other day had a nice burrito avocado on
toast with a poached egg yeah or you
have the beans on toast things
i like sometimes by jerry cinnamon he's
a scottish guy and he sings these
absolute belters he has a song called
belter it's glorious oh there's double
here oh sorry i didn't see that one what
color eyes does tom holland have look at
those gorgeous brown eyes look at those
you should stare at them super are you
are you zooming in give them the smolder
are we full on ecu right now
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh tom holland and zendaya
still friends
no
we're enemies
yeah we're frenemies
i just love to hate
i was never in a justin bieber video i
made a dance video to a justin bieber's
song when i was like cool 15. for
everyone watching the videos and they're
dancing just to people will be playing
in the description
click the link below like subscribe the
link is in the description you're
cancelled tom holland is cancelled party
wasn't a kid's mob kid i actually did
one kid's block music video
uh it's one of those those um things
where they like the song sing
kid friendly yeah i did one kids video i
wasn't actually saying that wasn't me i
was like listening into some random
person singing
that's cool that was really cool
what was the song because bob is the sh
is it katy perry song oh i think it was
hot and cold
i love that song
please don't do that either
wills and diabetes
hey you bet your bottom dollar that's
all i hope so yeah that would be a very
strange character decision you could
just like leave her out of the whole
thing yeah for no reason
okay do you like a gasp laughs so here's
the thing
that's what you do nothing actually
comes out
and there it is i'm being bullied
it's been called zendaya laughing now
okay i understand i get it but
i do i'm a very expressive laughter
meaning sometimes i don't really i'm not
really laughing as hard as i am but i i
do do this big face of like
every time i laugh that's just how i do
it okay
when did jacob batlon start acting 2016
when we first did spotterman oh remember
yeah was i was in drama school for a
little bit graduated thank goodness my
mother doesn't think i'm a total failure
who is jacob batlon's girlfriend the
amazing brook reyna she's the
lover to death we met on a night out
really random i feel like i wasn't
really looking for anyone and she kind
of just popped into my life and now
we're together
is jake about long friends with tom
holland honestly not really i feel like
we're kind of just putting this on for
camera yeah we get paid to do this a lot
of money so i'm not just like offended
that that's what they've good that's
what people google we need to yeah no
it's fine show the world is jacob battle
on
enrichy rich we were born in 96 so
probably not
but but thank you
tagalog
what does that say
sorry i couldn't see it from this angle
oh my god what does that mean tagalog is
uh one of the dialects that they speak
in the philippines oh i feel like i kind
of know a bit of every language in the
philippines i mean my family swears at
me in every
language like it's
uh pretty yeah pretty
uh salamat salaam
what does that mean that just means
thank you oh yeah what does no way home
mean it means you don't have a way home
which is a really depressing
foreshadowing of what the movie's about
yes
yes who is
the green goblin in no way home a
villain
a villain played by none other than
willem dafoe willem
do you know what harry started saying is
when people like are you going to be at
the party later he'd be like yeah willem
dafoe like remember we tried to yeah on
set and you were like no
oh defoe right yeah
i mean yeah willa yeah
i should be willing to vote
right what comic is spider-man no way
home based on i don't know
the way you looked at me like
i don't know
okay next one where does spiderman no
way home fit in the
timeline it fits in the timeline in
perfect sequence it's running
immediately it's not immediately out
it's not before it's not after it's just
right after the second movie yeah
is spider-man no way home stop
scratching christmas
it is not a christmas movie but it does
take place leading up to
christmas time so
santy claus what's next what's in there
oh mate it just goes wrong what award
did zendaya just win you just won the
fashion icon of the year i was going to
ask for that yeah also the youngest
person isn't going to have won it
and
greatly deserved what i add wonderful
work and also shout out to laura
who is also incredible
oh that's right you already know me
but yeah they said most
yeah
that's right it's hard to keep up with
all these things you're winning
for euphoria
again greatly deserving what are you
doing
experience it was
okay what video games does zendaya play
i know
you don't know i got really seasoned
playing video games so here's the thing
i'm not really good at
playing video games
make my friend come over it's like my
brother we play and i scavenge and do
all that stuff and he and then when she
pops out i'm like and he takes over but
yeah the spider-man game i've done all
by myself i was gonna say do you
remember that are you gonna tell
everyone that story is a certain
part and
i haven't played it since because
there's a bit on the spider-man game
that's in there couldn't do and i was
over at your house and i wouldn't and
she wouldn't let me complete this moment
for her no you know that's just the
price it's not for me yeah i know i want
to i want to figure it out i want to do
it no right you have your own life you
couldn't do it you have your own thing
going on you have your own there's
multiple games you can have going you
can have yours i want to do mine
what is india's favorite candy you like
um those those really gooey sweets the
flavory ones they're all flavory they're
sweets
you really like
just strawberry juice i will eat
strawberry high shoes when i'm shooting
because they i don't know it's just like
get you get you going
more informed information oh that was a
bad one i'm trying not to touch the
board why oh what does india have in her
nose and doom
it's the still suit which basically
allows for the people of iraq of arakis
to like
retain their water
so that
collects it
like a camel
yeah i mean technically yeah the water
is recycled cleaned filtered and then
used as drinking water whoa nice that's
actually i don't know i'll listen that's
like it's future type
why does tom holland use web shooters
well it
why does someone look so young in the oh
i didn't see that before sorry sorry man
i got you i got you the impossible
because i was
[Laughter]
that is the most if you're googling that
you're stupid
yeah you shot it last year i thought i
know i shot that movie when i was like
uh why can't tom holland dance because
he what on earth
hard work and dedication
why is tom holland so endearing yeah why
are you so endearing honestly i finally
yeah
i don't know the answer to that question
i just i haven't typed that yeah i don't
know who thinks that for sure
does spiderman work alone
shout out does spiderman get cold yes
for sure yeah but you have like the the
heat is on the inside of the suit yeah i
was actually thinking about that today
you know how we stand in the windows
we're like wow what it must be like
spiderman and i was thinking like damn
it would be cold
so cold swinging around it's like skin
tight as well yeah how did the other
ones do it does spiderman
have organic webs in some renditions
yeah yeah i know what i was but this one
definitely out of a web thingy not ours
umbrella hoodie oh yeah yeah so i
i don't know if it's some kind of like
etsy sort of website but basically i was
looking for uh things with our faces on
it i came across that hoodie and i came
across a sweater that said ello well
you're not zendaya i have a picture of
you um i have those and then i have one
of like ned printed on a shirt somewhere
my girl uses to sleep every night oh so
uh pretty cute
jacob battle on
jacked yeah no i feel like i was kind of
work hard consistently and all that
stuff but work got in the way and food
got in the way and now this show i feel
like i'm not really allowed to work out
on because i'm meant to be like
stereotypically not
a leading man type
but uh
eating vegan so i feel like i'm not as
badly unhealthy take a battle on
basketball pool yeah classic you know i
feel like that video actually
got me to a million followers on oh
really
that's an old-school video yes like
that's what it was on espn the other day
oh i swear to god every time every time
we do press espn just has to put it out
it's crazy shout out i love that love
y'all please have me on first take
stephen a smith
jacob babylon
bubble game bubble gang is a
filipino sketch show
that's really popular in the philippines
so when i did the press tour by myself
in asia by the way
yeah oh it was really dope that thing i
did in 2019 it was so fire and it was
like it was the best time of battling
enzyme handshake
to make him feel left out
intentionally
who does spiderman love
come on now so many people yeah ned mj
ant-man uh happy hogan tony stark
you're loved by many and hated
by loads of people 7.2 billion people so
many haters in this movie yeah is
spider-man afraid of spiders tom holland
is i'm not the biggest fan of spiders
what is spider-man's black suit that is
the inside out suit uh which is very
cool we in the first film kind of showed
the audiences what the inside of the
suit looks like and ryan meiner ding who
is the designer of all the suits thought
it would be cool to see it in action so
yeah there you have it how does
spiderman dodge bullets
spidey says
is spiderman immortal no no
unfortunately not no no spiderman does
anyone really want to be immortal then
no i mean honestly no life's all right i
guess but i hope you enjoyed this i hope
you learned something new about the
three of us we always have a lot of fun
doing this we gotta clean up we do have
to clean up three
two one
watch out guys
[Music]